para una reacción s n 1 la s significa
sustitución y la n núcleo filo entonces
esta es la sustitución de un halógeno
por un núcleo filo es lo que sucede aquí
en la reacción general veamos el
mecanismo de una reacción sn 1 en el
primer paso del mecanismo
tenemos la disociación de nuestro
halógeno estos electrones se irán con el
halógeno que es nuestro grupo saliente
le estamos quitando un enlace al carbono
nos queda así ahora es un kart vocación
está cargado positivamente y nuestro
halógeno ahora tiene otro par de
electrones lo que le da una carga forma
negativa son buenos grupos salientes así
que el halógeno es el grupo saliente en
este mecanismo el siguiente paso del
mecanismo es la entrada del núcleo filo
aquí está nuestro núcleo
tiene un par de electrones libres está
cargado negativamente este núcleo filo
atacará al electro filo que es nuestro
carbó catión núcleo filo electro filo
cargas opuestas se atraen este par de
electrones libres formará un doble
enlace con este carbono y eso nos dará
este producto en donde el núcleo filo
sustituye al halógeno y tenemos un kart
vocación en nuestro mecanismo este es el
kart vocación
carbó ocasión
recuerden que puede haber un posible
arreglo hay que tener cuidado con
reacciones del tipo s n 1 en términos de
velocidad de reacción el primer paso es
la disociación del halógeno ese es el
paso más lento
lento
y el segundo paso es el ataque núcleo
físico que es muy rápido rápido
tenemos un paso lento y un paso muy
rápido cuando se hacen estudios de la
velocidad de reacción global sn 1 la
velocidad sólo depende de la
concentración de nuestro alumno de
alquilo la ley de la velocidad de la
reacción general queda así p es igual a
la constante de velocidad k por la
concentración únicamente de nuestro
alumno de alquilo entonces la velocidad
sólo depende de la concentración del
alumno de alquilo porque el primer paso
es la etapa determinante de la velocidad
de reacción toma un poco más de tiempo
la disociación del halógeno que lo que
tarda el ataque núcleo físico que es muy
rápido además el ataque núcleo físico no
puede ocurrir hasta que el halógeno
salga la pregunta es porque la velocidad
de reacción sólo depende de la
concentración del alumno de al kilo
tal vez les sea más fácil si usamos
algunos números supongamos que la
disociación de la luz del kilo tarda
diez segundos obviamente no es un número
cercano a la realidad pero es para
darnos una idea y el ataque núcleo
físico sólo tarda un segundo la mayor
parte del tiempo la reacción se
encuentra en el paso lento y podríamos
saber cuál sería aproximadamente la
velocidad global de la reacción por el
tiempo que tarda el primer paso el más
lento y el segundo paso no puede ocurrir
hasta que ocurra el primero entonces no
importa qué tanto aumentemos la
concentración del núcleo filo no podrá
atacar hasta que exista la formación del
kart vocaciòn
esa es otra manera de verlo cambiar la
concentración del núcleo filo no afecta
si no tenemos un kart vocación presente
muy bien a esto se le llama sn 11 que es
un y molecular es decir sólo depende de
la concentración de uno de los reactivos
que es por supuesto el alumno de alquilo
la etapa determinante de la reacción es
el paso más lento en nuestro mecanismo
ahora veamos qué tipo de alumnos de
alquilo pueden someterse a una reacción
s en eeuu no sabemos que se forma un
kart vocación veamos dos tipos de
alumnos del kilo y encontremos cuál de
ellos reacciona más rápido por la vía sn
empecemos con este alumno de alquilo
este de aquí pondré a un cloro por aquí
dibujaré otro por acá para el segundo el
uno de alc y lo pondré dos hidrógenos
abajo en lugar de esos grupos metilo que
teníamos arriba
si hacemos reaccionar estos dos saludos
de alquilo cada uno por el mecanismo sn
1 el primer paso sería la disociación
del halógeno nuestro grupo saliente
estos electrones se irán con el cloro y
éstos se irán con este cloro que nos
queda
bueno para este ejemplo nos quedaría un
kart vocación como éste
y en el segundo ejemplo
así nos queda el carb ocasión
por aquí están los hidrógenos
clasificamos a los carbó cationes este
carbono de arriba está unido a 123
carbonos así que es un kart vocación
terciario hagamos lo mismo para el de
abajo este carbono con la carga positiva
está unido a otro carbono así que es un
kart vocación primario tenemos un kart
vocación terciario y uno primario en
vídeos anteriores vimos que un kart
vocación terciario es más estable por la
hiper conjugación y también es más
reactivo porque es el que se formará más
experimentalmente este ejemplo de un
kart vocación terciario contra uno
primario es como de 50 millones a uno
pero es sólo para que se den una idea en
términos de estabilidad los carbó
cationes terciarios son más estables que
los demás es más fácil que reaccionen en
mecanismo por la vía sn 1 y por
extensión los saludos de alquilo
terciarios este de aquí es un alumno de
alquilo terciario son los más reactivos
en un mecanismo por la vía sn 1 porque
el kart vocación terciario que se forma
en el mecanismo es más estable si
queremos ordenar a los saludos de
alquiló el alumno de alquilo terciario
es el que reacciona mejor en un
mecanismo por la vía sn 1 seguido por el
secundario y luego el primario y después
podríamos poner el metilo si quieren
así que el terciario es el más rápido en
un mecanismo por la vía sn uno veamos si
podemos hacer los mecanismos para
algunas reacciones sn unos simples si
tenemos a esta molécula como nuestro
reactivo el cloruro de ttr butilo y lo
hacemos reaccionar con acetato de sodio
que es una fuente de aniones acetato el
cloro es nuestro grupo saliente pero
cuál es el núcleo filo la carga negativa
del par de electrones libres en el
oxígeno funcionará como núcleo filo así
que el primer paso es la disociación y
aparece un carbó catión terciario aquí
es donde el núcleo filo atacará al
carbono cargado positivamente y al final
nos queda la sustitución es una
sustitución núcleo física hagamos otro
empezaremos con ter butanol
le pondré los pares de electrones
hagamos reaccionar del butanol con ácido
clorhídrico hcl con sus pares de
electrones
en esta reacción el h no es el mejor
grupo saliente porque si estos
electrones se van con él lo h nos
quedaría 1 h - que no es tan estable
como los halógenos pero si tenemos
algunos protones presentes podrán formar
un mejor grupo saliente empecemos con
una reacción ácido base si este par de
electrones toma este protón deja a estos
electrones que se quedarán con el cloro
que nos quedaría se forma agua como
grupo saliente ya hemos visto esto antes
este par de electrones no hizo nada y
nos queda una carga positiva ahora si
los electrones salen junto con el
oxígeno nos queda el agua como grupo
saliente que es más estable y como ya lo
hemos visto en muchos mecanismos se
forman nuestro carbó catión por aquí
tenemos una carga positiva
recuerden aún tenemos a la unión cloruro
por acá que está cargado negativamente
funcionará como nuestro núcleo filo un
par de electrones atacará a nuestro
carbó catión nos queda el producto que
es el cloruro de ter wood y lo hagamos
uno más
veamos otra vez un ejemplo con el
cloruro de ttr butilo aquí tenemos al
cloruro de éter butilo reaccionando con
metanol aún no les he hablado de
solventes en este vídeo pero por ahora
este será nuestro solvente el metanol
será nuestro solvente y también será el
núcleo filo a esto se le llama reacción
de sol policies la sol 'bolis is es una
reacción de sustitución específica en
donde el núcleo filo es también el
solvente sabemos que este par de
electrones se irán con el cloro en la
primera etapa para formar un carbó
catión terciario si nuestro solvente es
el núcleo filo no está cargado
negativamente como en las otras
reacciones pero este par de electrones
libres del oxígeno funcionarán como
nuestro núcleo filo este es el núcleo
filo que atacar a nuestro electro filo
dibujo
el resultado de este ataque núcleo
físico un par de electrones en el
oxígeno forma un enlace con este carbono
de aquí si teníamos un hidrógeno unido a
este oxígeno un par de electrones no
participó en la reacción el oxígeno nos
ha quedado con una carga formal positiva
para el siguiente paso del mecanismo hay
una reacción ha sido base que ocurre al
final así que otra molécula de metanol
entra al mecanismo
esta vez en lugar de actuar como el
núcleo filo actuara como una base este
par de electrones tomará a este protón
dejando a los electrones que se quedarán
con el oxígeno y así se forma nuestro
producto
este es un ejemplo de sol ball isis en
el siguiente vídeo hablaremos sobre el
stereo selectividad de una reacción sn 1